tom holland is known for his commitment
to big action stunts and taking a hit or
two on set but how did he fare on those
super dangerous ones well we're here to
help figure those out here's to a look
behind some of tom's most dangerous
stunts and action sequences he decided
to take part in let's dive on in with a
harness of course
number one tom makes those spidey jumps
look so easy and even the ones where he
has to be so precise can get a little
nerve wracking as peter steals the
machina de cadavers from doctor strange
in no way home he jumps onto a moving
car and then backflips onto the ground
many would have thought this was all cgi
but no holland takes fate into his own
hands actually doing the stunt with a
moving car he wasn't all that free
having harnesses and whatnot but even
then he could have missed his mark and
serious injuries could have occurred we
know he's turned stunned professional
after his first two spider-man films but
this is just masterful number two all
those acrobatics are bound to get you
injured and with all the stress on your
knees they'll be the first to go that
was the fate of our poor peter parker
during a scene in no way home and this
one was pretty serious production forced
him to take a few days off to recuperate
which was nice but he was not all that
happy to be out he was really just
trying to find his way back saying i'm
chomping at the bid to get back to work
and back on set but the film's going
really well we're sure they had to
accommodate him with some knee braces
afterwards
number three dangerous stunts are not
something to laugh about but when the
persons involved come out of it with a
good laugh we can't help but laugh with
them as peter gets discovered by the
world as spider-man he freaks out a lot
prompting him to run around mae's
apartment in complete disarray and
apparently crash into stuff as well poor
holland got a little too excited on the
slippery floor and crashed right into an
unsecured bookshelf not only could this
have resulted in a bad head injury but
it could have derailed the whole film
though he was such a good sport about it
and got right back to filming the scene
number four tom was busy in 2021 filming
two back-to-back action blockbusters and
unfortunately with great action comes
great injury as uncharted got into the
thick of filming with the more dangerous
scenes holland faced his ultimate
challenge yet nathan drake jumps out of
a plane in midair dodging falling cars
and cargo boxes now to sell this kind of
a stunt tom was given pretty complex
instructions to keep him safe and sell
the stun but he wanted me to get hit and
then slide off that way so it took a
long time to get right number five
holland really went all out with the
stunts on this film there was never a
dull moment for him during filming as
this was about a treasure hunter
embarking on a dangerous adventure take
home injuries with a new norm but some
were a little too serious to just brush
off i walked away from every stunt but i
definitely limped from a few tom recalls
the scene where he took a pretty nasty
fall onto some roof tiles leaving him
with a badly bruised hip but he saw
these dangerous stunts as a way to make
the film even better
number six when you give a couple actors
some swords things can get a little cut
throat good thing that wasn't what it
resulted in for holland in this
uncharted sword fight but he didn't walk
away from it with a good outlook he
recalls his fight alongside co-star mark
wahlberg as one that he'd be glad never
to visit again we can't help but think
what if someone made a false move prop
swords can still hurt a lot but we're
glad that all he walked away with was a
bad outlook on sword fighting
number seven filling in the shoes as an
executive producer can give an actor a
lot more choices to work from uncharted
became very important to tom and he
wanted everything done with the most
effort felt that sense of responsibility
to bring this character to life he
trained for weeks to nail down those
dangerous stunts that we all know and
love from the video game when all is
said and done tom walked away with some
pretty nasty injuries from shooting but
to him that was all worth it i can
honestly say i have really done the work
to make this character you know live up
to your expectations in every way
possible
number eight holland's involvement in
chaos walking hit him a lot in the face
when he announced that he broke his nose
for the first time fans were to say the
least worried about his well-being it's
not the first time either that he'd
broken his nose but for this one it
probably could have been avoided as
director doug lyman prompted tom to do a
little flip in between takes he just
fell flat on his face holland puts it in
more layman's terms so i stood up i had
these stupid leather boots on i tried to
do a back flip and just broke my face
and right to the hospital he went maybe
put down a few cushions next time tom
number nine this behind the scenes
moment had us on the edge of our seats
for chaos walking we find our spidey
actors scaling walls yet again and we
sincerely all production designers use
prop paint it's not a big deal to see
tom climbing walls but when they're
rusty and he's jumping and grabbing
parts of the wall we get a little
concerned hopefully he had his tetanus
shots in order
number 10 with harnesses being a part of
tom's film career you'd think you'd feel
a little safe in them but taking a full
midair swing and holding your co-star in
the process can make things really risky
even zendaya had a nerve-wracking time
staying cool with spidey but little did
she know his peter tingle was on the
fritz with this stun
number 11 it's gonna take a little more
than a light rain shower to take this
spider out you'll need a whole lot of
cold water to get the job done
spider-man far from home fully initiated
holland into the stunt profession
enduring dozens of extreme stunts on big
locations but one in particular he was
not a fan of and this was the one where
peter gets slammed into a railing by a
blast of cold water as if the cold water
wasn't the worst of it he was hurled
into this railing multiple times to get
it right talk about back pain
number 12 getting stuck in a
free-falling elevator is not so fun but
what about lifting one yes we know tom
didn't actually lift an elevator but he
did have to hold his body up and crash
through the doors he was just getting
into stunt work and this one was
dangerous for the fact that there were
so many factors involved even though
there were some strings attached tom
just gave it his all facing the risk of
injury
number 13 all it took for parker to
become spider-man was a spider bite easy
enough and now he can do all the flips
and swings he wants holland on the other
hand had to train a lot to prepare for
the stunt heavy far from home he worked
closely with coordinators to train for
weeks leading up to filming but it
seemed nothing could prepare him for the
dangerous sequences he was about to do
number 14 since a lot of what spider-man
can do is superhuman it totally couldn't
have been done without the help of cgi
that didn't mean that tom got a little
break from the set but instead
he was fitted up with some motion
capture attire and put to work with some
stunts these acrobatics could have been
dangerous to do on an actual set so
doing it with all the necessary padding
sure was a load off for him
number 15 there's definitely a thrill in
performing dangerous stunts and holland
really worked with everyone to get the
best ones done collaborating with stunt
doubles and coordinators he was actually
allowed to perform some on the fly
stunts he imagined it really served his
character more this way making him a
pretty believable peter parker
number 16 if there's one thing tom
dislikes about stunt heavy films it's
harnesses there's no amount of prep you
can do to make a harness comfortable but
really we never really see him without
one while he's donning the suit or
nathan drake persona with his break from
acting we're sure we won't see tom near
one anytime soon we'd like to say no one
was hurt during the process but
unfortunately for tom he took home a few
injury trophies throughout the years
would you have fared as well as tom in
those scenes
let us know in the comments
[Music]